is joint work with with mike jordan and
it's about trying to understand some
questions at the the interface or
intersection of statistics and in
computation and it's motivated by the
following sort of setup that shows up in
many other domains as well and it's
where you are an advertiser and you wish
to participate in an auction in an ad
exchange see if some user that visit
some website and if some maybe
information about this user and based on
what he or she may have searched for or
the sorts of information that he or she
seeks online you have you can place a
bid on whether or not you want to
advertise your product and some panel
somewhere and in these ad auctions the
decisions that you need to make the
amount that you're willing to pay to
place your ad is guided by you know a
whole ton of information that you have
about users typically but not very much
time to make those decisions so the sort
of setup is a lot of data to try to
address to try and figure out at what
level you want to bid but very little
time to make these decisions frequently
on the order of milliseconds or even
less and this is somehow different from
the kinds of constraints that we have in
statistical estimation theory these
sorts of constraints we typically think
about are the amount of data and so in
classical statistical analysis the
notion of a minimax estimator a minimax
analysis in general is what central de
estimation Theory trying to compute the
best sorts of estimators or consider the
best sorts of estimators that operate
given a fixed amount of data rather than
trying to take into account time are
these sorts of constraints the people of
the pad so again repeat that because it
wasn't clear typically folks have
considered in classical statistical
analysis the amount of data is the key
constraint and what's the best
estimation performance you can obtain
given given a small amount of data but
in these sorts of problems that I just
described
is the key bottleneck and data is
typically plentiful so what's the best
decision that you can make in terms of
risk and a bounded amount of time is the
sort of question that we want to
understand to be able to address to be
able address questions like this okay so
we need some informed way in many machs
analysis to be able to incorporate time
constraints and so a simple experiment
to to try to understand just I've just
thrown some toy numbers in here to try
and understand how we might try and
think about this problem right so
consider a typical scenario where you
are given five thousand data points
think of these data points as being
independent and you run your computer
for an hour and you get a risk of point
oh three now you're given five hundred
thousand data points you run your
computer for 20 days to solve the same
estimation problem on the same entrance
task and you get a risk of point 0003
much smaller risk but suppose I tell you
that I'm happy with a risk of point 0 3
and I give you 500,000 data points what
should your response be this is again
you know a toy version of the setup that
we had before where you have a ton of
data and you want to make decisions and
a bounded amount of time you're happy
with the risk of point oh three but you
have a lot of data so it should be clear
at least of the data or exchangeable or
iid that you shouldn't need to run your
computer for more than an hour right
because I can just take a subsample of
5000 run my computer for an hour and get
a risk of point of three if they did are
homogeneous or iid in general why might
this be reasonable why might I be happy
with a risk of point 0 3 in many
settings this is reasonable because in
many cases I may not care about such
small improvements of risk from say
point O 3 to something like that and
many other settings statistical models
are only approximations to reality they
aren't reality so when I'm trying to
estimate parameters accuracies of this
type
quickly more than more than sufficient
to make to make informed decisions and
so is it possible for more data to lead
to less computation and so let me
explain what I mean and this sort of set
up in the story set up it should be
clear that in this case you should never
need to run your computer for more than
an hour right you can just take 5000
points run your algorithm for an hour
and you're done but is it possible that
using 10,000 points at 20,000 points or
100,000 points you can obtain the same
risk so you don't improve your risk but
with the payoff being that you can
reduce the amount of computation
required you should certainly not have
increasing computation as the desired
risk is fixed but can you reduce
computation as you have more and more
data and this is somehow a tension
between computer science at some level
and statistics at some other level and
numerical computation specifically these
sorts of analyses that we conduct our on
trade-offs between runtime and error and
runtime typically quantified and say
iterative algorithm is via the number of
iterations so I'll you know run an
algorithm with a certain number of
iterations 50 iterations versus hundred
iterations how does my error decay as a
function of the number of iterations
this is the typical kind of analysis or
thinking in a numerical computation and
statistics the traditional way of
thinking about things is in the
trade-off between amount of data and the
best error you can obtain or the error
that you can obtain with a specific
enfance algorithm so what are trade-offs
in this in this 2d axis so as I get more
and more data at what rate does the risk
decrease of the optimal estimator of or
of a given specific estimating right but
we don't typically think of trade-offs
in this setting where a fix the desired
risk of the fix the desired accuracy and
ask how can i create off amount of data
for computation certainly for a fixed
desired risk you need a minimum under
data to be able obtain that risk
beyond that minimum level can I use
extra data to to reduce computation and
so that's the space in which we'll talk
about things in in this talk and so the
first few slides are just about what we
can hope to obtain from trying to
understand time data trade-offs at a
fairly general level what can you
possibly obtain what are these sorts of
statements you can make given the
current state of the art in statistics
given the current state of the art in
computer science and then I'll move on
to a very simple statistical inference
problem and talk about our convex
optimization specifically the notion of
convex relaxation can help you obtain
these sorts of time data trader okay so
I'm going to view inference procedures
as points in this plot so by that I mean
I'm going to consider an inference
problem abstractly stated think of it
you know think of a parameter estimation
problem perhaps where you fix the
desired risk fix the desired accuracy to
what you want to solve the problem and
you view infants procedures as points of
this plot and see if number of samples
in one axis runtime and the other axis
and you hope to be able to obtain plots
like this whereas you have more and more
data you reduce runtime with the idea
that you still obtain the same fixtures
okay now anytime you have a plot that
attempts to understand trade-offs the
first question you should ask is would
the vertical lines in this plot mean and
what the horizontal lines in this clock
right so what is the vertical line in
this plot a vertical line of this plot
means to obtain my fixed risk what is
the smallest amount of data that I need
independent of computational
considerations what is the minimum
amount of data required to obtain a
desired accuracy estimate and this is
relatively well understood and many
domains we understand many machs risk
bounds in statistics for many many
classes of
they're still interesting open questions
here but this is a rich and well
developed feel the complementary
question you can ask is on horizontal
lines what is the minimum amount of
computation required given access to an
unbounded amount of data to obtain your
fixed risk and of course in this sort of
setup you do need to take into account
the computation required in our access
data and even basically processing
everything but you're given in-principle
access to an unbounded amount of data
and what's the minimum amount of time a
minimum number of operations required to
obtain your fixtures this even in many
other settings in computer science is
not as well understood this is you know
the central open question in computer
science and complexity theory
specifically and it depends on various
things it depends on the computational
model for instance the Turing model may
or may not be the most appropriate model
if you're thinking about numerical
computation if you're thinking about
solving a sequence of linear systems
perhaps you might want different atomic
blocks atomic units of computation if
you want to think about lower bounds and
computation here but in any case this is
on the whole much less well understood
than then vertical plants is inverted
winelands but our hope is to try and
understand somehow trade-offs given you
know what this blood the lay of the land
is in in each of these fields and so one
some very very basic things you can say
in that in the abstract in general or
that as I give you more and more data
you need some mechanism to be able to
back off to a weaker algorithm if you
use the same algorithm with this many
data points as you would with this many
data points you are going to increase in
runtime and you're going to obtain a
decrease in risk if you use the same
algorithm on more data points this is
less so what you need as you're given
more and more data as some mechanism to
be able to back off the simpler
algorithm
with the idea that if I can process a
larger data set more coarsely I might
still be able to obtain the same desired
risk but that I might be able to do so
with less computation so we really need
some mechanism for algorithm weakening
it is also the case that if I give you
lots and lots and lots of data and you
live in a setting where access the data
or even touching each data point has a
cost associated with it at some stage
you will need to throw away data and so
you should expect to see plots that look
like this now of course this depends on
the specific computational model that
you have it depends on the specific
space of algorithms that you consider
and we'll see examples of this too and
in a few slides and the last thing is
that will trade off runtime upper bounds
given that obtaining lower bounds income
you know in terms of computational
complexity or difficult what I'll create
off what I'll talk about are trade-offs
of the following kind as you give me
more data I'll give you a different
algorithm that has a smaller worst-case
runtime upper bound so they'll have a
smaller upper bound rather than trading
off global balance this is very
different from these sorts of trade-offs
you see in other domains like in physics
or other settings where you trade off
lower bounds we talk about conservation
laws and so on so this will be a
trade-off involving upper bounds yeah so
some of these worst-case upper bounds
for these sorts of algorithms what I'll
talk about our are tight so there will
be instances of problems that attain
those upper bounds it is in general not
clear if the specific instances that
arise in statistical estimation meet
those upper bounds so I mean there is a
lot of lot of interesting there's a lot
of interesting questions to ask you even
at the level of phrasing the right kind
of question but i think it is still
reasonable to talk about trying to use
weaker algorithms because we do
recognize on a computer at least if i
can run a simpler algorithm it will run
much faster and so it is reasonable at
least
time to talk about this okay and so this
is all you know these are all things I
said sort of in the abstract about a
generic estimation problem if you will
but getting to these specifics the
simplest possible estimation problem
that I could think of when we started
working on this was the normal means
problem and this is the problem where
you have a signal corrupted by Gaussian
noise and the signal comes from a known
set so these signal lives in P
dimensional space and it comes from a
set that's known to me the specific
point itself is unknown but this the set
is known and I observe n iid samples
from this process so n samples of
normally or Gaussian corruptions of
effects okay that's clear that the
sample mean is a sufficient statistic
and a natural estimator that you can
write down is to take the sample mean
and project it onto the signal sadness
right this is in some sense the most
natural thing you could do now this
frequently turns out to be difficult
depending on the kinds of signal sets
you care about for instance signal sets
that are based on sparse models are
typically difficult to project on the
signal sets that have some sparsity
structure in them as well as structure
involving rank constraints which are
also common in many applications are
very very difficult to project onto
directly and so a natural thing to try
to do is look at convex relaxations
where you project onto some convex set
that i'll assume is a superset of your
signal set s okay and this is very much
in the spirit of what has been going on
over the last 10 15 20 years in machine
learning and statistics and related
fields where we shrink on to convex sets
for computational tractability so this
goes back to you know shrinkage
estimation statistic goes back all the
way to the late 50s and early 60s but
especially
the beginning with the work of Donovan
Johnstone shrinking or projecting on the
convex sets for purposes of
computational tractability is is a very
nice thing to do for many many reasons
and there are many interesting surprises
many interesting phenomena that occur in
high dimensions by that I mean large p
see if signals living in very high
dimensions p and more recently shrinking
not just on to the l1 ball as and word
donovan johnstone did but shrinking on
to other sorts of convex sets is also
something that's that's very popular
it's a very common thing to do so this
idea of replacing complicated-looking
sets by convex sets for reasons of
computational tractability is something
that's very much in the spirit of of
what's been going on over the last few
years in statistics and computer science
or sort of a processing and a machine
learning okay so to try and understand
the performance of this estimator we
need to have two definitions to be able
to state the main theorem the first one
is a definition on the computational
side or on the convex geometry side and
it's and it involves the cone of
feasible directions of a convex set so
if I have a point X star in a convex set
what are the set of directions that I
can go to locally where I still remain
in the convex set and that's so this is
a toy example of what I just had X star
is a point and a complicated looking
said I take a convex relaxation of ave s
the signal set and the set of directions
I can go into are all these directions
to the cone of feasible directions
that's on the computational side or on
the convex optimization side on the
statistical side the key concept that we
need to be able to talk about
performance of that estimator that I
just wrote down is the Gaussian
complexity I put a squared in here
because there's a square but it's
defined as follows given a County the
Gaussian complexity of the cone is the
soup over all normalized vectors of the
in the cone of the inner product between
your Gaussian ran
noise and this vector in the column but
the square the expectation is with
respect to this gas so again just two
basic concepts one from from convex
geometry and one from machine learning
and this notion of Gaussian complexity
also has other names of you if you look
at different literature it's called the
Gaussian width in some cases as well and
the risk of that estimator X had M of C
recall that X hat n was the estimator
given you know formed by taking n
samples taking the sample mean and
projecting out of the convex set C is
given as follows it's Sigma squared over
N times the Gaussian complexity of the
cone of feasible directions at X star n
to see so if the cone is very narrow the
Gaussian complexity is small and you get
a tighter Arab which makes sense if
there's no constraints at all so the
cone is all of our P then this quantity
will be will be very large and you get P
in fact if in fact you you're not doing
any projection you would get P and
that's exactly the risk of T of the
sample mean too straightforward very
simple simple result to prove you can
generalize it the cases where you have
non Gaussian noise you can obtain better
sorts of bias variance trade-offs but
those are those are lower level details
the high-level idea is that the Gaussian
complexity of the scorner feasible
directions is what controls the risk of
your estimate okay all right so what
this means going back to the philosophy
that we had right at the beginning of
the talk is that if you fix the desired
risk what sorts of statements can you
make so if we fix the desired risk to be
say one then the number of samples that
you need by reordering these terms has
to be lower bounded budgets this
quantity right so if I have n greater
than this quanta
so Sigma square times the Gaussian
complexity then I'm guaranteed to obtain
an estimator with a risk of at most one
so this less than or equal to 1 and then
just rearrange terms and so what this
means for time data trade-offs is that
if I give you a very very large amount
of data n so n is a big big number I can
use as large a convex set as possible so
that this time Sigma squared is still
less than or equal to n right so this
quantity recall is monotonic and the
convex set C because a sea becomes
bigger the kona feasible directions
becomes bigger and the Gaussian
complexity becomes bigger ok so if I
give you a very large end you can use as
large as see as is feasible so that
Sigma squared times this complexity
involving c is less than or equal to n
and again we can show that the pictures
you have a complicated looking signal
said you take one convex relaxation of
it which is c given by this grey area
you can take a relaxation of it given by
C Prime the cones of feasible directions
expand and you got the gaps in
complexity is extent so if I can now
prove for you or show you a mechanism
whereby larger convex set C are easier
to project onto than smaller ones then
we are done right if I have a large
amount of data and I can use a very
large convex set if I can show for you a
mechanism we're projecting onto a larger
set is easier computationally than
projecting onto a smaller one then we do
obtain time data trade-offs right as you
have more and more data take a larger
than larger context at project onto
easier and easier sets computationally
and you'll obtain a weaker and weaker
estimation and so this is something that
is the result of a ton of really
beautiful work in the convex
optimization literature this idea that
if I have
structured signal sets i'm going to say
algebraic with insults that the convex
hull of s can be approximated in a very
nice way via a sequence of of convex
sets and what's interesting about this
family of approximations is that it's
order not just by approximation quality
but also by computational complexity so
that projecting on the c1 is easier than
projecting on the c2 is easier than
projecting on the c3 and so forth and
this is something I d a--'s received a
lot of attention even in even in the
computer science community because it's
one of the most popular ways to design
approximation algorithms for hard
problems these sets these approximations
can be polyhedral approximations so then
you live in the domain of linear
programming they can be semi definite
approximations in which case you'd live
in the domain of semi definite
programming and so on and so forth and
these are all the names associated
associated with these with these ideas
and just as a small detour what's
central in obtaining these sorts of
approximations that are ordered both by
approximation quality as well as by
computational complexity is this notion
of lifts and projectors so there's one
takeaway that you take from the stock
from the optimization side of things
it's this idea that I'm going to
represent a convex set in P dimensional
space is the projection of a set in it
space that's larger than P dimensions
and as I as the listing dimension the
larger dimension space becomes bigger
and bigger I obtain better and better
approximations to my original set in P
dimensional space but I also have to pay
a greater and greater cost
computationally and so this idea of lift
and project is what is central to to
obtaining these these hierarchies of
relaxation so the point I wish to make
here is that in general it is not the
case that projecting onto a larger
convex set is easier than projecting
onto a smaller one but what is true is
that projecting onto a very specific
family of larger and larger convex sets
specifically based on these lifts and
project
ideas does in fact give you this
ordering in terms of computation
complexity as well as in terms of
approximation quality so these are very
specially designed convex sets on to
which projection is easier as you get as
you get larger and larger sets okay at
this stage I've been a meant to mention
this previously but I think this is the
most appropriate stage to mention a ton
of previous work on computational and
statistical trade-offs a lot of this was
even done in the setting of binary
classifier learning as opposed to the
normal denoising problem that I've that
I've been talking about it goes back all
the way to early work and in the late
1990s there was this term called
computational sample complexity used by
used by some folks in CS theory more
recently in machine learning sure she
left shorts and now the cerebro and
their colleagues have done a bunch of
interesting work in the setting of
binary classifier on one sort of general
point of contrast with all these all
these papers versus versus what i'll
talk about in the coming slides is that
in these papers you need a ton of extra
data to be able to back off the simpler
algorithms and what we will see in the
examples coming up is that in the
denoising problem this is very much a
feature of the b noising problem is that
you just need a modest amount of extra
data to be able to back off the simple
around some other work that i'd like to
point out is in sparse pc and related
problems involving clustering and
network inference Martin Wainwright and
a student or a shammy needed some
interesting work here there's very
recent more interesting work by philippe
regally and a student i'm trying to
obtain lower bounds in the case of
sparse pca just this that relates to the
question that was just brought up and
there's also interesting work by Alec
agarwal and Peter bottles and john duchi
on oracle and equalities model selection
that incorporate time constraints as
well as as well as sample constraints
but instead of general high level
contrast all these previous piece of
work our work i think emphasizes this
notion of algorithm weakening
the idea that you really need a
mechanism to back off the simpler
algorithms as you have more and more
data and that convex relaxation is a
very nice way to accomplish this
algorithm weakening it's sort of the
only general principle approach I know
of that allows you to do this in many
many different settings and a lot of
popular algorithms in machine learning
these days are based on on convex
optimization and so I think these ideas
are potentially very useful in practice
too okay so before we get to our
specific examples how do we calculate
runtime there are two operations
involved in computing than estimating
computing estimates based on the
estimator I described one is to compute
the sample mean so that's n data points
times P and then the next is the number
of operations for projection I
projection onto onto the convex set C
computing the sample mean increases as
you give me more and more data because n
increases as more data but the number of
operations for projection because you're
projecting onto a simpler set decreases
and our hope is that this decrease is
larger than this increase and so you do
actually obtain time data trade-offs and
this is something we'll see concretely
and some examples the next thing I want
to point out is how do you estimate
Gaussian complexity there are very
general methods to do this based on
Dudley's integral formula involved in
covering numbers and so on for the case
of convex combs the specific sense in
which gaseum complexity appears here
where I take normalized vectors in a
cone and take P squared these sorts of
covering number arguments tend not to be
the sharpest tools to use and so one can
prove a more specific theorem for the
case of convex cones which goes as
follows if I have a convex county where
the dual of the cone has relative volume
you so that's the fraction of the sphere
that the dual if the cone covers then
the Gaussian squared complexity is given
by by this quantity so let's see if we
even make sense that a sort of
superficial high level right if I have a
factor in factored County it's dual
becomes thinner and thinner so the
relative
volume of the duel becomes smaller and
smaller and so 1 over mu becomes larger
and so it all sort of goes in the in the
right direction so for a larger county i
will have the degassing complexity girls
or thesis bound rose and this is the
proof based on gaussian iso perimetry
where you don't need to look at all
possible cones where they do all his
relative volume you you only need to
look at the spherical cone would do will
have in relative volume you and so that
somehow is an extreme example exactly in
the spirit of of isoparametric
inequalities and this is also something
that we we proved essentially this
result in an earlier paper with with
been direct Pablo / alone animals okay
so get him two examples the first
example is one that's motivated
conceptually by problems in
collaborative filtering and in plus
Turing where the signal set s consists
of Rank 1 matrices made up of just plus
or minus one so other products of of
plus minus 1 vectors the best convex
relaxation that you could use is the
convex hull of s this is called the cut
polytope and projecting onto this fall
at hope as far as we know requires time
that super polynomial in P if you could
project under this Paul Paul it open
polynomial time you'd be able to solve
max cut which is an np-complete problem
in polynomial time but if in principles
you could project onto the spotlight
hope the number of samples that you need
to obtain a risk one estimate is a
constant times square root of T this in
fact you could project on to that part a
common relaxation of this polytope is
what's called the ellip top this is the
relaxation used in the Goldmans
Williamson approach to solving the max
cut problem is it semi definite
relaxation and this has run time p to
the 2.25 the best algorithms the best
general-purpose algorithms require the
sort of run time to project onto the
ellip top the numb
samples required in this case to obtain
a risk one estimate is a different
constant times square root P where this
constant is larger than this one the
final relaxation you could use is to
project onto the nuclear normal this is
the convex hull of rank one matrices the
reason you might want to do this is
because you recognize that the signal
set is composed of Rank 1 matrices are
projecting onto the convex all of Rank 1
matrices is a reasonable thing to try to
do and this has run time based just on
the SVD of P to the 1.5 note that the
signal lives in P dimensional space so
it's a square root P by square root P
size matrix so that's the reason you
have these strange-looking exponents and
if you did this the run the number of
samples required for a risk one estimate
is a different constant times square
root P and so just by increases in
constant factors you can back off to
very very simple algorithms the next
problem is actually something that Alex
talked about and our motivation here was
actually based on banning estimators for
covariance matrices where a natural way
to band based on the work of peter bikal
and Lisa lavina was to threshold all the
entries away from the diagonal and this
is a reasonable approach if you have a
good ordering for random variables but
in cases where you don't have a good
ordering you'd have to adopt an approach
like what Alex described and a stylized
version of the problem that I'll talk
about is where m is a known fry diagonal
matrix and the signal set is all
possible shuffling of the rows and
columns of N and so you want to jointly
estimate the covariance matrix and the
ordering that gives you that makes
banding a reasonable thing to try to do
again the best possible context
relaxation you could write down requires
time the super polynomial and this is
the number of samples for a risk one
estimate you make the observation that
every element of the signal set because
ms tridiagonal is a sparse matrix and so
you can use the l1 bomb as a ball under
which your project and the runtime in
that case goes down drastically and
again at the expense of
just a constant factor increase and D
and the amount of data a third example
where we also see a constant factor
increase in the amount of data is where
the signal set consists of all possible
perfect matchings in the complete graph
this shows up in problems and network
tomography and a network inference rich
Beranek and others have done some
interesting work involving these sorts
of structures in this case projecting
onto the best possible convex relaxation
actually requires polynomial time but
you still get a dramatic reduction by
observing that every element of the
signal set consists of the same number
of ones and the same number of zeros and
so you can project onto a different
object in an convex geometry called the
hyper simplex and you get a dramatic
reduction in n run time again at the
expense of a constant factor in the
number of set points the last example is
one where we actually have more than
just a constant factor increase in the
number of samples and it's motivated by
sparse PCA and related problems where
the signal set is basically a clique
platted inside a a larger graph the
click is planted on square root of the
nodes of a larger graph and square root
is an interesting scaling based on ideas
from you computer science in this case
the convex hull is again hard to project
onto requires fourth root of P many
samples projecting onto the nuclear norm
in this case request square root P
samples so there is an increase there
but the runtime Goes Down Goes Down
dramatically so this is one case where
you have more than just a constant
factor increase in the amount of data
required ok one question for the
audience why is it that I could project
onto an even simpler convex set than the
nuclear normal right the Euclidean ball
is even easier to project onto the
nuclear number the number of samples
required goes from square root P to P if
you want to obtain a risk one estimate
why is it that I didn't have this third
line in the previous example or the
examples before that
the reason I didn't is that this is in
principle easier to project onto
projecting onto the Euclidean ball
requires just time order P but if you
have order P samples that you need to
process what is the total run time it's
n times P to compute the sample mean and
then order P operations to project so
you actually end up with order P squared
total run time if you are not evilly
adding up n numbers so the
pre-processing step of even computing
the sample mean is so much that this is
not a reasonable thing to try to do
you're better off just taking square
root P of square root P of these samples
and applying the nuclear normal brooch
now scores this and in this case it
makes sense to throw away data and this
goes back to to this sort of flattening
of the plot that I had right at the
beginning now of course there are lots
of caveats here adding numbers is you
know a very efficient operation at least
if it's done in parallel where is the
projection operation is something that
needs to be done somehow more seriously
if you will and so there are lots of
considerations lots of caveats and being
able to make these sorts of claims if
you want to make these claims formally
you need computational lower bounds as
was pointed out but at least depending
on the space of algorithms that you use
and the kind of computational
infrastructure you have there will be
cases where it makes sense to throw away
data because trying to plot trying to
get to that extra data actually costs
you computationally in ways that are not
beneficial okay one interesting question
that I took away at least from all this
is that in many many cases it seems that
you don't need too many extra samples to
be able to back off to really simple
algorithms and this is in contrast to
the sorts of things you see in computer
science some of the relaxations are used
to project onto were very weak
relaxations if you take the viewpoint of
approximation ratio so the approximation
ratio of the relaxation
relative to the original set was very
bad this is the quantity of interest of
your end objective assay combinatorial
optimization or some other problem that
is typically considered of that type
that's typically considered in in
computer science if your end objective
is inferential then approximation ratio
is not the quantity of interest the
quantity of interest is somehow how
these Gaussian complexity scale as you
use weaker and weaker relaxations so you
can or geometrically this is the sort of
thing you care when you look at
approximation ratio you take the
worst-case linear functional and look at
the gap between the relaxation and the
original set in our case we care about I
mean there are two differences relative
to this you care about how the corners
of the set fatten rather than how most
of the mass of the set behaves so it's a
more algebraic property rather than a
more metric or geometric property the
second contrast to this is that an
approximation ratio typically one
considers worst-case gaps if you will
between the original set and the
relaxation whereas in our setting we
care about Gaussian complexity so we
somehow average guys in the cone rather
than taking the worst-case guy but if
you have these if you incorporate these
two differences you get radically
different performance using for
statistical inference problems than for
combinatorial optimization problems
because using very weak relaxations
actually makes sense now because you
just need a constant factor more data
relative to say a combinatorial
optimization problem where the
approximation ratio would be so bad and
using these relaxations that you
typically consider them to be not very
useful okay so talk about some
challenges with massive data sets and
specifically the role that massive
amounts of data can play in trying to
reduce computational run time I talked
about this concretely in a very specific
denoising problem and finally talked
about trade-offs via convex relaxation
using convex relaxation
as a mechanism for for algorithm
weakening I think there are many
interesting avenues to future work
certainly going to more more interesting
families of problems beyond more
interesting families of estimation
problems beyond the one I talked about
is if interest like I mentioned the
previous slide Gaussian complexities of
these hierarchies of LP or SDP
approximations to convex sets as I think
of interest relative to approximation
ratios of these hierarchies and I think
it's also Ventress to consider other
mechanisms for weakening algorithms
beyond convex relaxation things like
dimension reduction or clustering as
interesting pre-processing steps to try
and scale up the massive data sets will
not increase in computational runtime i
think is are all day reasonable things
to try to do thank
basically just in the iid assumption I
guess I mean an appointment at least in
what I described it wasn't taking a
smaller sample size it was just
aggregating a larger sample size but if
in fact you were the subsample at least
in the setup that I talked about the
data points are iid so there's no sense
of sort of adversarial or worst case
although yes in cases like that I think
something that's something that departs
from what I talked about would be would
be
that's interesting that's an interesting
question i would i mean i would think
that if you have any information about
your distribution you would use that
information to try to design your convex
set appropriately to try and I mean a
reasonable thing to try to do is to try
and have their convex relaxation be very
tight near sort of the worst-case parts
of your distribution and have it be
relatively weak or loose and parts that
there are far away from the worst-case
parts right so well then I i would still
imagine being able to make certain
claims but i don't know if this at least
what I talked about directly applies
thanks